-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy and Peabody Award-winning
journalist who hosts "Anderson
Cooper 360" weeknights on CNN.
His "New York Times"
best-selling book, "Vanderbilt:
The Rise and Fall of
an American Dynasty" is out now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Anderson Cooper.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-How are you doing?
-I'm doing really well.
I feel like this is --
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Very happy you're here.
-Thank you.
-This is maybe
a byproduct of the fact
that I see you on TV
all the time.
I did not realize you have
not been here since 2017.
-I had no idea.
-That's a long break.
-I see you on TV all the time.
-There you go.
-It's better that way, really.
-It's better that way, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is already awkward, yeah.
But congratulations.
You have had a baby boy
since I last saw you.
-I have, yes.
-Here's Wyatt right there.
Look at this guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
18 months.
-He's 18 months old.
-Pretty good time?
-It's the best thing ever.
-Talking, chatting?
-Yeah, lots of, you know...
"Shoes" is his favorite word
and "paintings."
He says, "Au revoir."
-Oh, he says "au revoir?"
-The latest thing he --
Just yesterday we taught him,
"Where did it go?"
And so he just goes around
going, "Where did it go?"
[ Laughter ]
He doesn't know what it means,
but...
-He knows it's like a button.
He's like it's the perfect thing
to say.
-And it goes up.
-Yeah.
-Halloween.
What are you guys going to do?
-Halloween seems to be like --
It's like an arms race
with these kids
and the Halloween costumes,
especially with, like,
well-known people's children.
They seem to put pictures of
them out on --
It's like a -- Yeah.
-And if you haven't planned
in advance, it's already
too late.
-Oh, my God.
-Supply chains are down.
-Yes, I know.
-It is too late.
-So, a friend of mine named
Chip Kidd, who actually did
the book cover of "Vanderbilt"
and is an old friend
of my mom's,
he is a Batman-obsessed
and has an amazing
Batman collection.
He gave me -- or he gave Wyatt
a costume his mom made for him
when he was a kid probably
in the early '70s.
-Wow.
-It's a homemade cape --
Batman cape with,
like, a cheap plastic --
Do you remember those --
I don't know how old you are,
but those Halloween costumes
when I was a kid were just,
like, a weird one-dimensional
mask and a tiny piece of elastic
that just go around it.
-It was back when people thought
a really healthy thing
to breathe all night
was plastic.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
It was completely flammable.
So that's what I bought --
I have for Wyatt.
-There you go.
-A very flammable costume.
-I feel like vintage fashion
is, like, the highest end,
whereas vintage Halloween
is, like, very low end.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm trying to bring that back.
-Yeah, low end, cheap Halloween.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I tried it on him
and he wasn't really thrilled
with the whole mask yet.
-Yeah, he'll get used to it
if he wants his candy.
-I think it's the kind of thing
he'll look back on and think,
"Oh, that's cool. I was wearing
a vintage Batman costume."
-I love that you are now
officially a parent
because your logic is, "You will
look back on this and like it."
[ Laughter ]
"It's not my fault you can't
appreciate the present."
[ Laughter ]
What about -- I have heard this.
We're kind of the same,
I'll admit.
Try to limit screen time.
-Yes, I'm obsessed with
limiting screen time.
Although it's hard because,
you know, if I'm at work,
occasionally, in between
commercial breaks, whatever,
I'll just call to check on
how he's doing.
And he's not allowed to
look at a screen --
Not allowed.
I mean, we try to avoid it.
But he will now grab the screen
while I am FaceTiming with
Benjamin, my former partner,
and he will run with it
like a crazy albino monkey.
[ Laughter ]
And it's the greatest thing
ever.
Like, I love it because it --
It's like his point of view
of the world.
-Yeah.
-And he's just like...
[ Babbling ]
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- Yeah, I love it.
-I haven't been able to --
I'm trying to impress this
upon my boys,
which is when they FaceTime
with my parents, they do that
and I want to -- like, I can
tell my parents just need to
get off the phone because
they're, like, old
and it's giving them a headache.
[ Laughter ]
For them, that's
a roller coaster of like,
"Let me show you
what I've been doing."
And they're like,
"Well, you know what?
Send us a still photo."
[ Laughter ]
You, as a young man,
you dressed up a lot.
I mean, I guess
this is very in line with
a Vanderbilt upbringing.
-Yeah, it is weird.
I look back and all the photo --
I sent some because
all the photos of my childhood,
I'm wearing costumes,
and this isn't for Halloween.
-This is not Halloween.
This is just around the house.
-This was any given day.
-That's normal.
That's normal.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah, that was
my knight outfit.
-You're doing a very good job
here of not smiling.
[ Laughter ]
-That was my theater outfit.
My brother wearing
my knight outfit also.
Yeah.
-So there you go.
So that was always part of it.
-Yeah, it was.
It was the '70s.
This was the early '70s, and --
-Kids dressed up like knights
in the '70s.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-What was trick-or-treating --
Growing up in New York City,
what was trick-or-treating
in New York like in the --
-People think it's weird.
I would --
My friend Michael Youckto lived
across the street
in a high-rise.
And so we would -- I would go
over there and trick-or-treat.
And it was great
because the elevator --
That was back when -- like,
buildings then had
elevator operators,
and they would put up a list
in the elevator of
who wanted to be bothered
and who didn't want
to be bothered.
So you knew your success rate
was like 100%.
Because you wouldn't bother
with, like, the old lady
who didn't want to, you know,
have you come to the door.
-Was it about 50/50?
Like, what percentage of
New Yorkers in the '70s
were cool with kids in costumes
coming to their door?
-You know, in the building
I went in, it was fine.
-Alright.
-But, yeah, you know.
-Were you nervous?
I mean, I feel like everybody --
-Like, 20% of the time you
got blades in the apples.
[ Laughter ]
But I mean.
-That's fine.
-But it was totally --
No one thought about it then.
Like, it was just --
it was unwrapped candies.
-Yeah. Just like --
-Marathon bars.
Remember those long
Marathon bars?
-Oh, you got a Marathon bar,
that's a day maker.
I have a lot to ask you about,
especially the book.
We'll be right back with
more from Anderson Cooper.